انت سائق سيء ربما تعرضت لهذا الاتهام
مسبقا من قبل اصدقائك واسرتك الان يمكنك
الرد دون ان تكون دفاعيا جدا فلديك دراسه
جديده تدعمك قياده رديئه فعلا لكن الامر
وراثي لا اكثر
لكن هل فعلا يمكن ان تكون القياده السيئه
وراثيه موقع سيارات بريطانيه اجر استطلاعا
على اكثر من الف سائق على مدار عشره اعوام
لمقارنه سجلات القياده الخاصه بهم بسجلات
والديهم ومراقبتي ما اذا كان هناك ارتباط
في عادات القياده السيئه بين الاباء
وابنائهم اظهر البحث ان السته وستين في
المئه من السائقين الذين خالفوا قانون
المرور واجه ابائهم مشكلات مروريه ايضا
خلال نفس الفتره بين منخفضت نسبه الى اقل
من الربع عند السائقين الذين امتلك اباؤهم
سجل نظفا
[موسيقى]
كانت السرعه والغضب اثناء القياده السمتين
الاكثر شيوعا التي تنتقل من الاباء الى
الابناء بينما قال سائقون اخرون ان ضعف
الوعي بالمكان والقياده العدوانيه
اكتسبوها من والديهم
اخيرا ينصح الموقع بعدم استخدام حجره
القياده السيئه الموروثه امام المرور حيث
لن تشفع لك على الاغلب عند سحب رخصتك منك
[موسيقى]